[Música]
[Aplausos]
todos hemos contado un chiste todos
hemos hecho reír a alguien y le hemos
alegrado el día aunque sea un poquito
pero se imaginan que la comedia pudiera
ser una herramienta de transformación
social
o que pudiera devolverle el gusto por
vivir a una persona que está al borde
del suicidio
en 1970 patch adams fue el primero en
incorporar el humor al tratamiento de
los pacientes en hospitales esto con el
objetivo de ayudarles a superar la
ansiedad la depresión el estrés el miedo
usualmente ocasionado por el estar
hospitalizados por la enfermedad o por
los tratamientos que fueran a recibir
esto le abrió la puerta a un sinfín de
usos a la comedia e incluso en cosas muy
diferentes a lo que vemos hoy en día en
bares o teatros por ejemplo hay una
organización internacional de payasos
que se dedican a viajar por el mundo a
zonas en conflicto las zonas en guerra a
campos de refugiados
a donde llevan el alivio de la risa y
del juego a personas en situaciones
extremadamente difíciles
el tipo de comedia que yo he aprendido
es la comedia tipo estándar que se ha
vuelto muy popular en el mundo ha
llegado a restaurantes a bares teatros a
grandes estadios ha llegado a la
pantalla grande cine y televisión y ha
llegado incluso a cárceles y a
fundaciones
en méxico el estando que se ha usado
para ayudar a organizaciones civiles a
fundaciones y aún en casos de
catástrofes con shows a beneficio donde
se dona el total de la taquilla a la
causa o donde puedes pagar tu boleto con
un donativo esta forma de ayudar es es
muy atractiva porque siempre ayudamos
más cuando se nos da un pretexto y la
comedia es un buen pretexto
también aquí en méxico hay una fundación
que está empezando a enseñar estando en
cárceles de máxima seguridad
esto para ayudar a disminuir la
violencia y facilitar el proceso de
reinserción social
entonces ya hay un impacto este tipo de
comedia ya está impactando a la sociedad
de alguna manera pero para entender
mejor este impacto tenemos que
preguntarnos
qué le hace la comedia al individuo
y qué tiene que ver la comedia con el
dolor físico o emocional
hay cientos de estudios investigaciones
reportajes de psicólogos de terapeutas
de trabajadores sociales en campos de
refugiados que relatan como la comedia
estimula la empatía y es importantísima
para enseñarnos a lidiar con traumas
esto porque cuando reímos liberamos
químicos saludables como dopamina
endorfinas e interleucinas que son los
analgésicos y antidepresivos naturales
del cuerpo
cuando reímos también bajan nuestros
niveles de cortisona que es la hormona
del estrés esto literalmente disminuye
el dolor físico y la carga emocional el
estrés la ansiedad la depresión
el enojo
reír
libera la atención la asfixia la
parálisis del dolor y nos permite ir más
a fondo al mismo tiempo que disminuye el
impacto bioquímico del trauma en el
cuerpo
cuando estamos sanando un dolor profundo
reírnos a la distancia emocional que
necesitamos para lidiar con ello de
mejor manera y la empatía que propicia
en nosotros y en quienes nos rodean
acelera el proceso de recuperación
emocional porque nos enseña porque nos
recuerda aunque sea por un momento
que el dolor no es definitivo y que no
estamos solos
en una de las primeras balaceras de la
ciudad dos personas en una motocicleta
fueron a un edificio de gobierno al
lanzar tiros y esto paralizó a la ciudad
ese día todos los negocios cerraron
temprano la gente salió temprano de
trabajar las calles estaban vacías
y eso que tenemos esa noche se canceló
al día siguiente tuvimos show en otro
lugar las calles seguían vacías pero
llegó gente
y todos tratamos este este fin como de
que no
entonces me subí al escenario y les
pregunté están de humor para chistes de
narcos y dijeron
y me quejé del narco ese día no use mi
material yo estaba furioso porque dos
famosos con una motocicleta y una
pistola se atrevieron a aterrorizar a
una ciudad de un millón de habitantes y
una ciudad de un millón de habitantes se
dejó aterrorizar por dos babosos en una
motocicleta con una pistola y hablé de
cómo deberíamos ser más valientes porque
somos más si somos más les podemos hacer
bolita
si les podemos hacer bolita les podemos
dar sab es de hacerles calzón chino para
que le bajen a su changarro y deberíamos
aplicar esta fórmula a todos los
problemas sociales porque lo único que
necesita el mundo para que lo cambiemos
son dos cosas sabes y calzón chino
y la audiencia rió conmigo porque
audiencia y comediante necesitábamos esa
catarsis
necesitábamos recordar aunque fuera por
un momento que somos más grandes que el
miedo
y que no estamos solos
esto es lo que ustedes perciben de ese
lado del escenario
pero qué pasa de este lado que le hace
la comedia quienes la ejercemos que le
hace la comedia los comediantes
volvamos a las cárceles desde 1998 en
muchas prisiones de eeuu y canadá
aprender a hacer estando es parte del
proceso de rehabilitación de criminales
violentos porque disminuye los índices
de violencia y de reincidencia
esto porque aprender a hacer comedia nos
exige aprender a observar nuestro
entorno y nuestras historias ya cambiar
nuestra relación con ellas donde lo es
un giro entonces los ríos atraviesa en
este proceso de aprender a observar su
entorno a aprender a observar sus
emociones cambiar su relación con ellas
dándoles un giro y esto facilita que su
voluntad cambie de dirección y echen a
andar llevando a cabo acciones para
rehabilitarse y recuperar su vida porque
además les da condiciones bioquímicas
saludables en el cuerpo
es bien curioso como todos los que
aprendemos a hacer comedias sin importar
clase social color de piel pokemon
favorito
relatamos experiencias similares
nos sentimos más libres con más
autoestima aprendemos a reírnos de
nosotros mismos aprendemos a ser
empáticos a entender al otro entonces
empezamos a preferir entendernos a
nosotros y entender al otro antes que
ejercer violencia
es muy curioso como cuando uno piensa se
está riendo hacen se voltean averías en
este gesto como de taxi si se
identifican
los efectos más importantes de la
comedia tienen que ver con la vida está
el caso por ejemplo de daniel dónde
estás
danielle a él lo conocí desde el primer
escenario al que se subió y se ponía
súper nervioso le temblaban las manos le
temblaba la voz se le olvidaba su
material se le caían las notas
era difícil como audiencia era difícil
verlo
porque holly cap
porque lo veía subir intentarlo ponerse
nervioso
sabe el chiste no servía se pone más
nervioso era nueva era difícil pero de
este lado del escenario para él era
brutal porque él subía enfrentarse a
extraños y muchas veces a fallar
catastróficamente
pero el ejercicio de la comedia es el
ejercicio de seguirse atreviendo de
arriesgarse de atreverse de hablar de lo
que si queremos hablar y danielle
cecilio atreviendo
hace un par de meses lo llevé a su casa
y me platicó que él había estado en
terapia durante los últimos dos años y
durante el último año había estado al
borde del suicidio
pero
al empezar a subir al escenario al
empezar a atreverse al empezar a
arriesgarse al empezar a hablar de lo
que sí quiere hablar
ya no se quiere suicidar
ahora quiere contar su historia
reír es medicina y la comedia es el
medio que nos da la medicina de la risa
la comedia se da en este momento mágico
en el que sorteamos la distancia y nos
identificamos con el otro nos conectamos
nos reconocemos la comedia se da solos y
reímos juntos si yo hago un chiste
horrible y nadie se ríe no hay comedia
y si yo no sé empatizar si yo no sé a
entender al otro si yo no sé ponerme en
sus zapatos hay violencia
la comedia entonces puede ser este medio
de sanación y empatía que disminuye el
miedo y el dolor
hoy en día necesitamos reírnos más que
nunca porque nuestro estilo de vida está
lleno de estrés y de distracciones que
nos roban oportunidades de conectar con
el otro
necesitamos reír con alguien más que
nunca desesperadamente necesitamos reír
con alguien porque desesperadamente
necesitamos dejar de sentirnos solos
y es que además de esa inmensa necesidad
hacer comedia es muy duro
para que se den una idea de cada diez
chistes que escribimos los comediantes
dos funcionan
y 11 de ideal
o sea cuando tú ves un show de una hora
de comedia estás viendo el resultado de
cientos de horas de probar y escribir
material
nuestra labor de comediantes es
enfrentarnos en seco
a lo que duele a lo que molesta a lo que
incomoda a lo que avergüenza y nos toca
darle y nos toca enfrentarnos a ello y
nos toca cambiar la relación con ello y
darle un giro y probarlo y volverlo a
intentar y volver a cambiar la relación
con ello volverlo a intentar hasta que
el chiste funciona y la audiencia ríe
hasta que hacemos comedia
cuando hacemos comedia y se da esa
identificación
esa risa
descubrimos que no somos tan diferentes
yo suelo contar en el escenario que mi
mamá murió cuando yo era pequeño
entonces toda mi infancia fue gente una
tras otra diciendo medio disco y tú lo
siento
hasta que en algún momento yo empecé a
responder a la gente que me decía cuánto
lo siento
tú la mataste ya lo encontramos
en una ocasión bajando del escenario se
me acercó un chico y me dijo oye gracias
mi madre murió cuando yo era pequeña
también
y sé lo feo que es que te lo estén
recordando todos los días diciendo el
cuento lo siento
les voy a empezar a contestar como tú
les contestas
si descubrimos que no somos tan
diferentes
en lo grande y en lo pequeño
podemos empezar a procurarnos más desde
estos espacios en común podemos dejar de
lado poquito a poquito el miedo y lo que
nos duele para descubrir este magnífico
otro frente a nosotros
y así podemos entonces sufrir un poquito
menos y celebrar un poquito más esta
vida hermosa que tenemos
contando chistes
[Música]
[Aplausos]